[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as creative director at Red Storm
entertainment there's no greater reward
for me or the team than to see our game
come to life and to see our players our
star players taking tremendous pride in
being a part of the division now if you
haven't had the opportunity to play the
division 2 yet we would be thrilled to
have you join our very passionate
community because I'm happy to announce
that this week only between June 13 and
June 16th the division 2 will be
absolutely 100% free for everyone to
play
and there's no better time to join us as
we were about to release the first of
our major content updates for a year one
journey a journey beyond Washington DC
to save not just a city but an entire
nation
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right thank you
episode 1 coming in July right around
the corner we delivered to you new main
missions and a brand new game experience
so for the first time we're taking the
fight outside the city and you'll
venture deep into the woodlands to
spearhead an attack on a presidential
compound as you seek to bring a traitor
to justice the National Zoo is the
setting of our next mission where you
and your team will hunt down the
surviving outcasts leader and this
brings us to our final edition of
episode 1 a place called Kenley College
and it's home to an entirely new
gameplay experience one that will take
exploration investigation and logic to
uncover the fate of a military convoy
gone dark now episode 2 coming this fall
we'll bring to you the Pentagon once an
impenetrable fortress it has fallen to
the black tusks and its secrets are
about to be thrown out into the open you
must do everything it takes to secure
what lies behind the walls of this last
castle but this won't be the greatest
danger you face in episode 2 I'm very
excited to tell you that our second raid
will be coming this fall bringing back
intense 8-player action
what do you tackle the first raid it was
awesome and we cannot wait to see what
world records you break this time around
now this brings us to our third and
final episode of year 1
what if rebirth was not about bringing
in the world as we know it back to life
but the opposite one man holds that
power and humanity itself is at stake
agents it's time to engage in a manhunt
[Music]
in this chart
[Applause]
we had the training
[Music]
we fought to protect the weak
but training doesn't prepare you to on
someone you used to call brother
he has left us no other choice if we
don't stop him
there will be nothing left to save
holy [ __ ] what about that I can't wait
for that okay one last thing as you
might know we have been working on a
movie it will be directed by david
leitch starring Jessica Chastain and
Jake Gyllenhaal well today I'm proud to
announce that we will be making the
division movie with Netflix more to come
on that in the future thank you very
much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow hello everyone I'm Brenda Penner
grossie I'm vice president of platform
and product management Ubisoft has been
creating worlds for over 30 years we
have the most diverse library of games
and we're about to make it even easier
for you to play them I'm here to
announce Ubisoft's new subscription
service on PC called you play plus
[Music]
you'll get earliest available access to
new games including the premium editions
with all their additional content and
you can enjoy the depth of our PC
catalog that includes over 100 games and
growing
you play plus will be $14.99 a month if
you sign up today will enable free
access for you in September at launch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you wanna register fight the buffet
because this is war